.
HE GETS TO SAY WHAT HE WANTS.
THAT'S NO LONGER RULE IN A LOT
OF PACES.
ADAM CAROLLA JOINS US.
HOW DO YOU DO COMEDY IN A MOMENT
LIKE?
YOU STILL DO STAND-UP?
>> YES.
I WAS ON THE STAGE AT THE IMPROV
IN HOLLYWOOD LAST NIGHT.
I WAS ON STAGE WITH ANOTHER
COMEDIAN.
I STARTED GETTING INTO SOME
SUBJECT MATTER.
I COULD SEE IN HIS EYES, LIKE
DON'T GO THERE.
WE DON'T WANT TO GET INTO
TROUBLE.
AND THAT'S A VERY TROUBLING
NOTION.
COMEDIANS SECOND-GUESSING
THEMSELVES.
WORRIED ABOUT GETTING INTO
TROUBLE.
AND ALSO THIS NOTION OF THESE
IDIOTS SAYING BECAUSE A COMEDIAN
SAID SOMETHING, PEOPLE ARE GOING
TO GO DO IT, AS IF YOU DID
WHATEVER GEORGE KARLIN WAS
TALKING ABOUT IN THE '70s, OR
RICHARD PRYOR, EVEN ACCUSING
TRUMP OF PROPELLING PEOPLE TO
INJECT BLEACH.
OKAY, HE'S DANGEROUS BECAUSE HE
TOLD PEOPLE TO INJECT BLEACH.
HOW MANY AMERICANS INJECTED
BLEACH?
THIS IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THIS IS THEIR EXCUSE FOR
CANCELING EVERYONE, BECAUSE THEY
KNOW PEOPLE DON'T LISTEN TO DAVE
CHAPPELLE OR TRUMP SAYING TO
INJECT BLEACH.
IT'S A EXCUSE TO HAVE DOMINION
OVER YOU.
>> Tucker: IT MAY BE, HOWEVER,
THAT THEY'RE ON TO AT LEAST ONE
POINT, THE ONE THING THAT
AVERAGE PEOPLE MIGHT COPY FROM A
COMEDIAN IS THE WILLINGNESS TO
MOCK THE PEOPLE IN CHARGE.
MAYBE THAT'S WHAT THEY FEAR.
THEY DON'T WANT TO BE MOCKED.
>> YEAH.
AND THERE'S A DEFINITE TRUTH IN
COMEDY THAT CUTS RIGHT TO THE
CORE.
THEY KNOW IF THEY LOSE AND CAN'T
SILENCE THAT COMMUNITY THERE'S
GOING TO BE ISSUES.
REMEMBER WHEN JOHN STEWART WAS
ON STEPHEN COLBERT'S SHOW
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO, AND HE WAS,
LIKE, HELLO, WUHAN LAB LEAK.
WATCH COLBERT'S REACTION TO
THAT.
OH, NO, ONE OF OUR OWN IS
CROSSING THE LINE.
IT'S NOT CROSSING THE LINE.
IT'S A COMEDIAN BEING FUNNY,
MAKING OBSERVATIONS THAT ARE
PATENTLY TRUE.
>> Tucker: SO HAVE YOU HOW --
I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED -- I DON'T
KNOW IF I'VE EVER ASKED YOU.
HOW HAVE YOU CONTINUED TO ACT
LIKE IT'S 1986 WHEN IT'S NOT?
WHY DOESN'T IT AFFECT YOU?
>> WELL, THIS IS GOING TO SOUND
SELF-SERVING, BUT YOU'LL SEE IT
ALMOST EVERYWHERE.
YOU HAVE TO BE GOOD.
IF YOU'RE GOOD, YOU SAY WHAT YOU
WANT.
DAVE CHAPPELLE IS GOOD.
JON STEWART IS GOOD.
THEY SAY WHAT THEY WANT.
MOST PEOPLE LIVE IN THE MIDDLE.
IF YOU'RE A JOURNALIST, AND YOU
HAVE ANY KIND OF INTEGRITY, YOU
QUIT YOUR JOB AT "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" AND YOU GO TO SUBSTACK.
THOSE ARE THE GOOD ONES.
MOST PEOPLE AREN'T GOOD.
MOST PEOPLE ARE IN THE MIDDLE.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE,
WHETHER YOU WORK FOR A BIG
CORPORATION OR "THE NEW YORK
TIMES" OR NETFLIX, YOU NEED TO
KEEP YOUR JOB.
MOST AMERICANS WANT TO KEEP
THEIR JOB OVER ABOUT ANYTHING
ELSE.
THEY'RE NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
THEY DON'T FEEL THEY'RE GOOD
ENOUGH TO SAY WHATEVER THEY WANT
AND DO WHATEVER THEY WANT.
>> Tucker: I MEAN, THAT'S A
REALLY GOOD POINT.
I WONDER, THOUGH, WHEN ALL OF
THIS ENDS, WON'T A LOT OF
COMEDIANS BE ASHAMED THAT THEY
WENT ALONG WITH SPEECH CODES,
WHICH ARE ANTITHETICAL TO COMEDY
AND FREE THINKING?
>> COMEDIANS EAT COUNT CHOCULA
IN THEIR LIVING ROOM EVERY
NIGHT.
THEY DON'T HAVE SHAME, SHAME
THAT THE REST OF AMERICA IS
CONSTRAINED BY.
SO NO, THEY DON'T NORMALLY FEEL
SHAME, THEY EAT EDIBLES, STAY UP
ALL NIGHT AND MAKE FART JOKES.
THEY'RE A HARD DEMOGRAPHIC TO
SHAME.
MY FEELING IS IF YOU'RE A
COMEDIAN, YOU GOT INTO IT TO SAY
WHAT YOU WANTED TO SAY.
IF YOU'RE CURTAILING THAT IN ANY
WAY, ESPECIALLY BECAUSE SOME
WOKE A-HOLES ARE GOING AFTER
YOU, THEN YOU'RE A COWARD, AND
YOU'VE GIVEN INTO THE MOB, AND
YOU BECOME A COMEDIAN TO
PUSHBACK AGAINST THE MAN.
THE MAN IS NOT RON DESANTIS.
THE MAN IS THE WOKE MOB, IF
YOU'RE A COMEDIAN.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT'S EXACTLY
RIGHT.
DO YOU WORRY THAT VENUES, WHERE
YOU'RE PERFORMING, CAN BE SHUT
DOWN?
>> UMM, NO, BUT IT DOESN'T IT
CAN'T HAPPEN.
I DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
I'M A COMEDIAN.
I HAVE TO SAY WHAT I'M THINKING.
SOME PEOPLE LIKE IT.
SOME PEOPLE WON'T LIKE IT.
THE SECOND THAT PROCESS ENDS, I
GOT TO GO BACK TO CARPENTRY.
>> Tucker: STILL LIVING LIKE
IT'S A F